Tony and Amelia's produce should bring
in $200 price tag for a litter of pigs
but this is their first farmers market
and they're facing stiff competition you
won't buy some stuff hi yeah yeah I'm
actually looking for honey and eggs
today we have a lot of eggs and we have
a lot of honey we've got some locust and
some wildflower honey okay I mean looks
pretty great I'm gonna I think like look
around and you know do a lap through and
wait come back alright well ours is the
best so come on back and get the best
okay
yeah well I'm fun looking around alright
thank you
we'll be here you're harassing the
customer maybe maybe I should let you do
it sorry these are get it um these are
free-range and then we feed them some
dumpster bread we get free bread and so
we feed him bread okay interesting and
then what's this like soup mix um no
this isn't soup mix this is dried oyster
mushrooms mixes $12 $12 each yeah I'm
gonna
have you got all right we'll be here
thank you
people keep saying I'll come back well
everyone wants to check out the big room
first
don't talk we have some competition over
there there's people selling eggs and
mushrooms there's a guy that's got a
whole table full mushrooms the mushroom
guru is here
they'll have about half an hour north of
town he's doing the other mothers just
we're just getting our feet wet yeah
yeah giving it a try
trying to make some cash money but I'm
here for eggs though we got eggs
yeah lots of a a little bit buddy Birds
sure yeah we have a type of chicken
called black Sumatra they are a smaller
size game and show bird you can see
these ones that are a little shawl or
those are the younger Birds they're
about six months and then as they get
older the eggs get a little bigger yeah
what I will take okay great
we're good eggs there you go so it's
four dollars thank you take care
something yeah